У цьому проморолику "Ти ніколи не один!" зірки Бундесліги
висловлюють свою повагу своїм вболівальникам.
Публіка - важлива складова футбольної містерії,
однак гроші вболівальників на стадіонах - не настільки вирішальні
для бюджетів топ-клубів, зокрема в Німеччині.
Принаймні це показав коронавірус.
Пандемія COVID-19 призвела до матчів без глядачів.
Німці називають їх "матчами-привидами" за тишу на стадіоні.
І все ж, футбольні клуби майже не помітили фінансових втрат.
Жоден німецький клуб не збанкрутував.
Якщо кілька місяців матчі проводяться без глядачів,
за які кошти тоді існують футболісти й клуби?
Головним джерелом прибутків у Бундеслізі є продаж медійних прав.
Телебачення перераховує німецьким клубам за право транслювати їхні матчі
за один лише тур Бундесліги 68 мільйонів євро.
Багато приносять і трансляції кубку УЄФА та Ліги чемпіонів.
Загалом на рік виходить майже 1,5 мільярда євро,
або 37 відсотків від загальних надходжень клубів.
Це пояснюється тим, що сьогодні основна маса публіки
дивиться футбол по телевізору, а не на стадіоні.
Телебачення справно платить й у часи коронавірусу,
аби тільки футболісти грали.
Друге за значенням джерело доходів німецького футболу -
гроші спонсорів та загалом реклама. Вони приносять 18 клубам Бундесліги
845 мільйонів євро за сезон, це 21 відсоток усіх прибутків.
В окремих клубах, як-от "Шальке", чиїм спонсором є російський "Газпром",
реклама забезпечує до третини доходів.
Третє за важливістю джерело  надходжень - трансфери футболістів.
У цілому Бундесліга виручає з продажу гравців набагато більше, ніж витрачає
на купівлю нових кадрів. Так, у сезоні 2018/2019 клуби заробили
на трансферах 675 мільйонів євро, або 17 відсотків усіх доходів.
І, нарешті, четверта складова у заробітку клубів -
це квитки на матчі та продаж їжі й напоїв на стадіонах.
Вони приносять клубам Бундесліги 520 мільйонів євро,
а це 13 відсотків сукупних доходів.
Сама по собі гігантська сума, якою клуби завдячують
найактивнішим у світі вболівальникам. У середньому на матч Бундесліги
приходять майже 43 тисячі глядачів, і цей показник не перевершила жодна ліга у світі:
ані італійська серія А, ані англійська Прем'єр-ліга.
А ціни на квитки у Німеччині не такі "кусючі", як у деяких інших лігах Європи.
Річний абонемент, що дає право відвідати всі матчі улюбленого клубу Бундесліги
у найдешевшому, стоячому секторі стадіону, коштує у середньому 180 євро.
Утричі менше, ніж абонемент в англійській прем'єр-лізі.
Квиток на сезон на знамениту мюнхенську "Баварію" можна придбати
узагалі за якихось 140 євро.
На деяких матчах гонорари "зіркових" гравців на полі - за цей один матч -
у рази перевищують виручку з продажу квитків на стадіон.
Через це футбольну економіку часто критикують за відірваність від публіки,
однак глядачі зрештою в виграші, адже можуть відвідувати стадіони за доступною ціною,
незважаючи на топ-зарплати деяких "зірок".
Продажі футбольної атрибутики - п'ята вагома стаття доходів клубів Бундесліги -
175 мільйонів євро. На шостому місці - інші джерела, включно з преміальними
за участь та перемоги у Лізі чемпіонів.
Футбольні клуби функціонують як великі підприємства.
Вони тримають нерухомість, шукають вигідні способи інвестування свого капіталу.
Окремі, як "Борусія" (Дортмунд), навіть виходять на біржу.
Отже, як показують цифри, футбол дедалі менше
економічно залежить від публіки на стадіонах.
Кожен матч без глядачів обходиться клубам у суму від 1 до 3 мільйонів євро.
Для когось це була десята частина прибутків, як для дортмундської "Борусії",
а для когось - майже половина, як для "Армінії" (Білефельд).
Але модель без глядачів насправді урятувала футбольні клуби від банкрутства.
Вони буквально "моляться" на стабільні "телевізійні" гроші,
без яких, напевно, не пережили б цю епідемію.
У новому сезоні Бундесліги вболівальникам у Німеччині
знову дозволено  ходити на стадіони, але за низки умов.
По-перше, стадіон має заповнюватисяне більше ніж на 20 відсотків.
По-друге, якщо в певному місті рівень захворюваності
переходить визначений епідемічний поріг,
присутність фанів знову забороняється до завершення епідемії.
Через це, приміром, у Мюнхені "Баварія" зіграла з "Шальке" за порожніх трибун.
Без глядачів, яких підміняють манекени, футбол проіснував вже кілька місяців.
Утім, довго він так не протягне, застерігають аналітики.
Мовляв, з часом відсутність жвавих стадіонів відіб'ється на привабливості спорту,
ну а це, зрештою, - і на доходах галузі.